and how many episodes are left before
Steven dies or whatever happens to him
well
arrow doesn't dial of this
arrows never dies I mean spoiler alert
if it doesn't die it's all they
don't die I don't know I don't know I
think you know just because a Batman
dies it's like it doesn't matter like
that movie us you're talking about when
those people in the beginning die you
know they're not gonna die these are
these are legendary
this is Batman this is uh these are you
can't kill Oliver Twist Oliver Twist
Oliver Queen you're really good at
what's the word zip lining your zip
locking your mouth what do you love
working with but like I know you're
gonna say everyone cuz you're such a
nice person but first for a second let's
not be as nice tell me who like when you
hear you're working with them today you
know it's gonna be the easiest day ever
you know that it's gonna be fun you know
it's not gonna be a pain in the ass I'm
not saying you don't love people equally
as much I'm saying who is that one
person that you just really get excited
to work with does it have to be just one
I'm really bad at a Vegemite God know
what - well you know what I would say I
had a lot of fun working with Steven
this year because I didn't get to work
with him last season at all given the
way the storylines were and now that you
know think thanks to crisis on Infinite
Earths the monitor brought me 20 years
in the past and I had most of my work
with Steven this season and it was
really so much fun why was it fun
he's just such an impeccable actor and
and I don't know there was something
about the way they wrote our scenes that
it was it put both of our characters off
of their studies and Father exactly
where our characters we were each
other's biggest biggest vulnerability
and so being put right in front of your
biggest obstacle of your entire life and
having to deal with that also knowing
the world is ending and all these other
things are happening it's it instantly
puts such confident characters out of
their comfort zone and as an actor
that's always fun to try and figure out